et sachez qu'en france les intermittents
du spectacle artiste conférenciers ou
encore extra de la restauration quitté
le théâtre de l'odéon ton ce matin
qu'ils occupaient depuis des semaines 24
heures sur 24 pour investir la salle
parisienne du 104 est également un
centre de vaccination n'occupe à sion
pour acclamer une deuxième année blanche
de retrait total de la réforme assurance
chômage déborah est artiste de cirque
elle était avec nous tout à l'heure où
notre volonté c'est d'élargir le
mouvement de continuer le mouvement de
continuer à nous battre
que ce soit en manifestation avec des
référés au conseil d'état etc etc
légalement publiquement pour pour
annuler cette réforme qui est absolument
abjecte et injuste donc effectivement
n'a quitté le théâtre mais on continue
et on est toujours là et on restera là
tant que tant que nous n'aurons pas
satisfaction
alors abandonné la contestation très
personnellement ça me paraît
complètement improbable on est très
nombreux ici est très déterminé à
continuer jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à ce que
la réforme saute donc abandonné le
mouvement ça c'est un non catégorique
après effectivement le mouvement va
prendre d'autres formes du fait encore
une fois qu'on soit maintenant plus
ouvert sur l'extérieur et voilà on va
pas abandonner sa c'est ça c'est sûr et
certain